ZD heute live euch e ein herzliches
Willkommen toll dass ihr mit dabei seid
3i Wochen nach dem Terrorangriff der
Hamas auf Israel sind die Auswirkungen
verheerend auch nach dieser Woche hat
Israel den Gazastreifen bombardiert nach
eigenen Angaben grifft die israelische
Armee in den letzten 24 Stunden mehr als
250 Ziele an darunter sein Tunnel der
Hamas sowie Raketenabschussrampen
gewesen wir sehen hier Bilder dazu in
der Nacht drangen auch israelische
Bodentruppen in den Gazastreifen ein das
Hilfswerk der Vereinten Nationen warnt
vor einem Zusammenbruch der öffentlichen
Ordnung in Gaza ja die angekündigte
Bodenoffensive bleibt der wah immer noch
aus aber laut israelischenem Militär
laufen die Vorbereitungen der nächsten
Phase des Kampfes auf Hochtouren wie es
heißt der wei Gerät parallel zu diesem
narostkonflikt auch die weltdiplomatie
inwanken Anfang der Woche gab es von
Isra israelischer Seite
Rücktrittsforderungen an den
Generalsekretär guterisch nach seinen
Äußerungen in einer Rede und viele
muslimische Länder werfen dem Westen
mittlerweile eine Doppelmoral vor fühlen
sich nicht mehr gehört und ernsthaft
wahrgenommen wir wollen deshalb heute
hier bei zdfute Live fragen wie ist das
alles einzuschätzen nach Kriegswoche 3
droht der narostkonflikt weiter zu
eskalieren darüber wollen wir reden mit
unserem Korrespondenten Michael bwerunge
in Israel mit unserer Korrespondentin
goline atai in Kairo und mit dem
israelischen Journalisten Gil jaron gern
gesehen wie immer eure Fragen die könnt
ihr uns stellen über die
Kommentarspalten oder gerne auch via
Mail an
zdfheute-li@zdfde zunächst schalten wir
aber nach Israel in telaviv steht mein
Kollege Michael beverunge Michael hallo
zu
dir hallo ähm das israelische Militär
das sind aktuelle Meldungen hat binnen
zwei Tagen zweimal Bodentruppen in den
Norden Gazas
in den Nord Norden des gasastreifens
geschickt was bedeuten diese
Vorstöße das sind Kommandoaktionen die
ganz konkret der Vorbereitung einer
Bodenoffensive dienen da gibt es immer
zwei Dinge das sind massive
Bombardements die sehen wir schon in den
ganzen letzten Tagen natürlich seit
Beginn des Krieges aber jetzt noch mal
ganz besonders und eben jetzt schon die
zweite größere bodenoperation mit
Panzern äh da geht es darum Aufklärung
zu betreiben schon mal erste feindliche
Stellung
auszu auszu zu vernichten sorry
und praktisch gucken was vor Ort für
Bedingungen herrschen vielleicht sogar
auch Verstecke von Geiseln
herauszufinden da hält sich die Armee
bedeckt was letztendlich genau das Ziel
ist aber es geht auf jeden Fall zur
konkreten Vorbereitung einer
Bodenoffensive der israelische
Verteidigung Minister hat erst heute
noch mal Journalisten gegenüber
bekräftigt dass die angekündigte
Bodenoffensive lang und hart werden
würde worauf zielt man da genau ab
innerhalb dieser
Bodenoffensive na ja das ist ein dicht
besesiedeltes Gebiet nach wie vor Häuser
jetzt zum großen Teil Ruinen aber
natürlich auch eine Struktur in der ein
konkreter Kampf am Boden sehr sehr
schwierig ist außerdem ist Gaza nicht
nur in nach oben bebaut sondern wie man
sagt sagt auch nach unten mit mehreren
geschossen das ist ein Netzwerk von
Tunneln und die Frage ist wie die
Israelis genau diese Bedrohung aus den
Tunneln wo sich auch die Hamas frei
bewegen kann vielleicht schnell von
einem Ort zu anderen verlegen kann ihre
Truppen wie sie dagegen vorgehen will
das ist auch noch Geheimnis der
militärischen Strategie aber das wird
auf jeden Fall ein Kampf Meter um Meter
aktuell läuft eine un Vollversammlung
auch schon seit gestern und wenn man
sich die Meldungen in dieser Woche
angeschaut hat hat sich dieser Konflikt
ja auch jetzt auf diplomatischer Ebene
ausgeweitet in der UN-Vollversammlung
wurde ein möglicher Gefangenen Austausch
angesprochen der Iran kam dann mit einem
Vorschlag da können wir mal kurz
reinhören was gesagt wurde auf der
Bühne Hamas ist bereit zivile
israelische Gefangene freizulassen im
Gegenzug sollte die Welt die Freilassung
von 6000 Palästinensern aus israelischen
Gefängnissen
unterstützen son ter Geiseln gegen
palästinensische Häftlinge das kam von
Israels Erzfeind kann man sagen den Iran
gab es schon Reaktionen auf dieses
Angebot ja das war nicht nur der erzfin
sondern offenbar der Komplize dieser
verbrecherischen Entführer der einen
konkreten Vorschlag für einen Austausch
macht da gab gibt es keine Reaktion
drauf das hätte wahrscheinlich die nicht
nur die Hamas gerne sondern auch der
Iran gerne es wird ja viel darüber
spekuliert wie groß der Anteil des Irans
an den Verbrechen am Massaker vom 7
Oktober ist und in Israel wird das
glaube ich erstmal sehr sehr
zurückhaltend gesehen es gab zuletzt
einen Austausch für einen Soldaten mit
fast 1000 Gefangenen darauf spielt der
Iran wahrscheinlich an aber momentan
geht es glaube ich erstmal darum einen
Großteil der zivilen Geiseln frei zu
bekommen es gibt noch wahrscheinlich
über 100 Soldaten und die sind für die
Hamas ganz besonders kostbar weil sie
gelten als direkte austauschkandidaten
für palästinensische Gefangene jetzt
gibt's knapp drei Wochen nach dem
Terrorangriff eine Umfrage Michael von
mariv die israelischen Medien haben
drüber berichtet 49% der Israelis würden
es demnach begrüßen dass mit der
Bodenoffensive noch gewartet wird was
sagt das über die Stimmung in der
israelischen Bevölkerung aktuell
aus
das sagt dass Israel nicht nur von außen
von Europa von den USA unter Druck steht
die Bodenoffensive aufzuschieben
humanitäre Korridore zu schaffen sondern
auch in Israel gibt es eine immer
stärker werdende Gruppe das sind nicht
nur die Angehörigen der Geisen sondern
eben diejenigen die auch mit ihnen
fühlen und die der Ansicht sind dass
eben diese Bodenoffensive mindestens
verschoben werden sollte damit mehr Raum
für die Freilassung von Geiseln ist das
heißt aber nicht dass eine Mehrheit
gegen eine solche Bodenoffensive ist
denn da gab es auch eine Umfrage vor
wenigen Tagen etwa zwei Drittel der
Israelis sind insgesamt dafür dass die
Bodenoffensive stattfindet um die
Bedrohung der Hamas dauerhaft
auszuschalten wir bekommen erste
userfagen rein Michael penilaos das mag
jetzt vielleicht dann auch sehr
spekulativ sein was man da beantworten
zu kann aber was ist mit den Geiseln bei
einer Bodenoffensive fragt
er na ja bei einer Boden Offensive
erstmal werden dann die Verhandlungen
wahrscheinlich sofort ausgesetzt und das
Leben der Geiseln ist sofort in Gefahr
allein schon deshalb weil die Hamas
angekündigt hat Geiseln zu töten wenn
diese
Bodenoffensive beginnt die Geiseln sind
das wichtigste Faustpfand der Hamas
nicht nur die militärische Gegenwehr und
Israel hat da eine offene Flanke und ist
sehr leicht erpressbar Einschätzungen
von Michael beverunge live aus Israel
Michael vielen Dank und ja du behältst
die Lage weiterhin für uns im Blick der
N ostkonflikt hat sich in den letzten
dre Wochen ausgeweitet mittlerweile ist
die ganze Welt die ganze Weltpolitik
damit eingeflochten nicht nur
muslimische Länder verurteilen den
Westen für dessen Israel Bekenntnis auch
die arabische Welt ist mittlerweile
empört unter anderem geht's da auch um
die deutsche Regierung in und die
deutsche Politik in Ciro sitzt unsere
ZDF Korrespondentin guline atai guline
hallo zu
dir der Westen habe eine Doppelmoral
diesen Satz den hast du in dieser Woche
öfters gehört du hast nämlich zu dieser
Geschichte auch recherchiert hast sich
mit verschiedenen Menschen getroffen
unter anderem auch ehemaligen ranghohen
Diplomaten und was die dir erzählt haben
das können wir mal ganz kurz uns
anhören der Westen hat ein enormes
Glaubwürdigkeitsproblem in der
arabischen Welt ihr verlangt vom
globalen Süden Russland zu verurteilen
weil es Land besetzt aber ihr verurteilt
nicht Israel für seine Besetzung von
palästinensischem Land eure
Doppelstandards sind für jeden
offensichtlich vor allem die deutsche
Regierung ist Teil dieses moralischen
Versagens des Westens in ihrer
bedingungslosen Unterstützung der
Besatzungsmacht Israel verhindert
Deutschland das Menschenleben gerettet
werden
können das sind jetzt zwei Meldung zwei
Meinungen die du
eingefangen hast mit der Kamera aber man
sieht das ja weltweit dass die Proteste
auch zunehmen also dass es wirklich
viele Menschen lautstark auf die Straße
bringt erzähl uns kurz woran stört man
sich da
genau man stört sich an Doppelstandards
also der Westen heißt es immer wieder
Messe mit zweierlei Maß und das sind
stimmen die man nicht nur auf der Straße
hört sondern das sind auch Stimmen von
ernstzunehmenden politikberatern von
Forschern die für und mitwestlichen
Institutionen hier zu Lande arbeiten die
immer wieder sagen dass es doch sehr
auffällig gewesen ist in den vergangenen
drei Wochen dass arabisches
Menschenleben so sagen sie weniger wert
sei als israelisches Menschenleben und
diese Signale in den öffentlichen
Botschaften westlicher Regierung habe
man fein erkannt und das habe ich hier
einfach für sehr viel Empörung für sehr
viel Wut für sehr viel Enttäuschung auch
gesorgt und auch was das Völkerrecht
angeht immer wieder habe ich habe ich
von diesen forschang gehört das
Völkerrecht ist nicht optional man kann
natürlich nicht die Ukraine Russland den
Russland Ukraine in Konflikt eins zu
eins mit dem Israel Gaza Konflikt
vergleichen aber der Westen macht sich
unglaubwürdig und er bringt seine eigene
internationale regelbasierte Ordnung in
Gefahr wenn er zweierlei Maß anlegt und
wenn er nicht so sehr wie auf Russland
auf Israel auch Druck ausübt das
Völkerrecht einzuhalten das klingt vor
allem auch danach dass diese
Anschuldigungen oder Vorwürfe gar nicht
so leicht oder so schnell zu lösen sind
für den Westen was für Probleme kann das
dann jetzt noch in der nächsten Zeit
bringen für die für die westlichen
Staaten ja die Rede ist immer wieder von
einem massiven Vertrauensverlust von
einem massiven geopolitischen
Flurschaden auch tatsächlich von einem
Scherbenhaufen ähm und sagen Diplomaten
hintervorgehaltener Hand auch dass es
wirklich viele Kollegen gibt die dem
Westen stets zugewandt gewesen sein aber
eben jetzt mit dieser Politik ähm sich
nicht mehr weiter mit dem Westen
engagieren würden ähm das ist ähm vor
allen Dingen aufgefallen in der ähm in
der Politik im UN Sicherheitsrat man hat
sehr bewusst diese US- Vetos
wahrgenommen und hat das als eine
westliche obstruktionspolitik im
unserheitsrat wahrgenommen und hat das
dann verglichen mit den vielen vielen
russischen Vetos die es gegeben hat im
Zuge der syrienpolitik als Russland eben
humanitäre Feuerpausen verhindern wollte
als Russland humanitäre Lieferungen
verhind wollte
ich fürchte eine Lösung eine Annäherung
wird wirklich schwierig werden westliche
Staaten haben in den vergangenen Tagen
ihr wording ihre Botschaften etwas
verändert sie haben ein ein humanitäres
wording auch immer wieder verhindert
eine Forscherin hat dieses westliche
Dilemma auch sehr gut auf den Punkt
gebracht sie hat gesagt natürlich
wünscht sie sich dass die USA jetzt
öffentlich für eine Feuerpause eine
sofortige Feuerpause eintreten aber
selbst wenn diese US-Administration es
wöte sie würde es öffentlich nicht tun
weil sie dann eben keinen Einfluss mehr
hätte auf die israelische Politik um
eben im Innern im Stillen sozusagen auf
Israel einzuwirken mhm die Kritik
richtet sich ja auch explizit auch mit
an Deutschland die ja nach der
Terrorattacke dann die Bundesregierung
gesagt hat wir stehen wirklich
solidarisch an der Seite Israels ähm
gibt es was haben wir deine
Interviewpartner irgendwie was erzählt
was man da erwartet z.B auch von der
deutschen Bundesregierung müsste man da
das Wording du hast das Stichwort ja
gerade gesetzt vielleicht auch
ändern ja also Deutschland müsste mehr
auf ähm humanitäre Hilfslieferungen
drängen es müsste überhaupt die die
Botschaft derjenigen Organisationen
internationalen humanitären
Organisationen und auch der
UN-Organisationen die seit Jahren im
gasestreifen engagiert sind äh
involviert sind äh auch mehr ernst
nehmen und ähm ja man ist einigermaßen
erschrocken äh hierzul Lande darüber
dass das eben nicht passiert mhm
Stichwort geiselfreilassungen da gab's
ja auch schon Erfolgsmeldungen die unter
anderem durch Ägypten angeheuert worden
jetzt nach diesem ganzen diplomatischen
tvabo was ich da gerade auf öffentlicher
Bühne abspielt was nimmst du wah in
Cairo bleibt man in der arabischen Welt
weiterhin trotzdem dabei dass man
weiterhin auch vermitteln möchte in dem
Nahostkonflikt ja auch wenn es jetzt
diese Vertrauenskrise gibt in Richtung
Westen natürlich hat man ein ganz großes
Eigeninteresse
daran diesen Konflikt irgendwie
diplomatisch zu lösen und es gibt auch
viele viele Anzeichen die darauf
hinweisen dass jetzt etwas in Bewegung
kommt
der saudische Außenminister hat es vor
zwei Tagen noch mal vor westlichen
Medien erwähnte hat gesagt
wir arbeiten ernsthaft daran dass der
der Friedensprozess wieder angestoßen
wird
Ägypten hat das immer wieder
signalisiert Ägypten ist allerdings ähm
als historischer Vermittler der ersten
Stunde in den letzten Wochen nicht
besonders erfolgreich gewesen bei den
Vermittlungsversuchen hat aber wirklich
ein Eigeninteresse aufgrund seiner
eigenen nationalen Sicherheit allein
wenn man sich anschaut was in den
vergangenen Stunden hier passiert ist
als nach
usinformationen eine Drohne ein
angeblich eine Drohne abgefangen wurde
die über ägyptischen Boden zerbossen ist
und hier auch ähm tatsächlich verletzte
hinterlassen hat und ich glaube die die
Rolle der Stunde im Moment die hat
das Golfemirat Qatar aufgrund einfach
seiner langjährigen Erfahrungen was
Verhandlungen angeht Qatar hat sicher
schon eingesetzt was die Freilassung
ukrainischer Kinder in Russland angeht
Qatar hat sich eingesetzt was die
Freilassung von iranischen Gefangenen
angeht und einem Gefangenen Austausch
zwischen den USA und Iran und Qatar ist
in den vergangenen Tagen erfolgreich
gewesen bei der Freilassung von zwei
amerikanisch israelischen Geiseln hat
weitere geiselfreilassungen angekündigt
es hat in den letzten Tagen ein Treffen
in Katar gegeben auch mit dem türkischen
Außenminister ich glaube da ist noch
einiges zu erwarten Einschätzungen von
goline ATI unserer Korrespondentin in
Kairo vielen Dank zu dir
goline ja wo steht der narostkonflikt
aktuell das fragen wir heute bei ZD
heute live weiterhin könnt ihr uns eure
Fragen Meinungen und Kommentare dazu
schicken und wir haben ja mittlerweile
gesehen auf wie vielen Ebenen dieser
Konflikt stattfindet und wollen jetzt
dazu noch mal sprechen mit Gil jaron er
ist Journalist und ein ostkorrespondent
in Israel geboren in Deutschland
aufgewachsen und mir jetzt zugeschaltet
hallo zu Ihnen Herr Eron guten
Tag schönen guten Tag vor drei Wochen
ereignete sich diese furchtbare
Terrorattacke der Hamas gegen Israel
nach ihrer Einschätzung wo steht dieser
Krieg
aktuell ich glaube wir sind um
vielleicht Churchill zu zitieren wir
sind am Ende vom Anfang dieses Krieges
aber das wird noch sehr sehr sehr lange
dauern ähm die erste Phase war die
Kriegserklärung der Hamas die
eingemarschiert ist in Israel mit mehr
als 1500 Kämpfern die 1400 Menschen
ermordet hat die Mehrheit Zivilisten die
sind jetzt aus Israels im Staatsgebiet
vertrieben worden israel hat seine
Reservisten zusammengezogen und bereitet
sich jetzt auf eine bodeninvasion vor in
der einen oder anderen Form und
gleichzeitig droht aber dieser Krieg
auch an vielen anderen Fronten zu
eskalieren wir sehen fast tägliche
Schusswechsel an der
israelisch-libanesischen Grenze aufgrund
von an wiederholten Angriffen der
libanesischen Hisbollah Miliz wir sehen
Angriffe aus Syrien wo es proiranische
Milizen gibt wir sehen Drogen aus dem
Irak wo es mehr als 100.000 Menschen
unter Waffen sind die vom Iran gerüstet
wurden genau für so eine Art von
Szenario und wie es schon angedeutet
wurde es gab ja die Angriffe aus dem
Jemen von huti Rebellen die drohen und
Marschflugkörper aus dem Jemen richtigen
Israel abgeschossen haben ein paar
wurden abgefrangen von amerikanischen
Kriegsschiff über dem Roten Meer und
andere sind jetzt in Taber in Ägypten
eingeschlagen wir haben gerade schon in
unserer Sendung Heron drüber gesprochen
dieser Krieg oder Konflikt hat
mittlerweile globale Ausmaße angenommen
wir haben dazu eine userfrage von Luke
bekommen der fragt war es ein Fehler
jahrzehntelang wegzuschauen was den
Nahostkonflikt angeht hätte die
Weltgemeinschaft da aktiver sein
müssen ich weiß nicht ob ob ob das Wort
wegschauen das Richtige ist den
auskonflikt war ja sehr prominent in
Medien und auch in äh der
internationalen Diplomatie spielt er
eine sehr wichtige und und prominente
Rolle
ähm die Frage ist hat man das Richtige
gemacht um diesen naostkonflikt zu lösen
darauf scheint die Antwort ja offenbar
zu sein nein man muss vielleicht man
braucht hier neue Ideen neue Denkansätze
das was man bislang gedacht hat was zu
einer Lösung führen könnte das hat ja
nicht funktioniert wir werden nach
diesem Krieg völlig neue Denkansätze
völlig neue Ideen brauchen um hier eine
neue Beruhigung herbeizuführen und so
fürchterlich wie kriege sind wir haben
ja gesehen in der Vergangenheit in dem
arabisch-israelischen Konflikt haben
kriege immer ein Momentum auch
hineingebracht das später natürlich auch
diplomatische Folgen hatte manche von
ihnen positiv wieder Frieden zwischen
Ägypten und Israel mm Merlin Pfeife
fragt welche Rolle spielt die Türkei sie
gehört ja zur NATO aber Erdogan sieht
die hamasia nicht als Terroristen an war
ja ganz prominent in dieser Woche auch
in den Schlagzeilen
damit ja die Türkei spielt ja eine eine
problematische Doppelrolle als äh nicht
nur hat Herr Erdogan sich ja sehr
positiv über die Hamas geäußert hat
gesagt sie sei keine Terrororganisation
sondern eine Befreiungsbewegung sondern
er beherbergt ja auch hamasisten die auf
türkischem Boden Attentate in Israel und
im westjornerland geplant hatten
und er stellt sich offen zu einer
islamistischen Terrororganisation wegen
der ideologischen Nähe er ist ja auch
eigentlich ein Anhänger der
Muslimbrüderschaft das ist ein
regionales Netzwerk von Bewegungen in
verschiedensten arabischen und
mehrheitlich muslimischen Ländern und
die Hamas ist Teil dieser
Muslimbruderschaft und Erdogan halt auch
und deswegen steht er zu ihr das macht
ihn natürlich für Israel zu einem immer
weniger akzeptierten Gesprächspartner er
hatte gerade erst vor wenigen Monaten
versucht sich israel anzunäheren hatte
den israelischen Präsidenten bei sich
empfangen aber ein Gegenbesuch scheint
im Augenblick ausgeschlossen die
Israelis sind nach diesem barbarischen
Angriff der Hamas nicht mehr bereit mit
Freunden der Hamas ein
freundschaftliches Verhältnis zu
unterhalten mhm unsere User fragen
etliches aktuell wir haben eine
ja militärisch spezifische Frage ich
weiß gar nicht ob sie die beantworten
können aber ich stelle sie ihn einfach
mal Herr Ron Sven fragt uns auf facebook
welches waffenpotenzial hat die
arabische Koalition gegen Israel und
würde sie auch diese Waffen einsetzen
wenn damit Palästina massiv gefährdet
wird nun die Frage ist wen bezeichnen
sie als die arabische Koalition es es
ist ja absurd zu sagen die arabische
Welt sei in der Frage Palästina ist
geeint die arabische Welt ist in so
viele verschiedene Lager gespalten und
das ist ja einer der Gründe weshalb auch
das Palästinenser Problem wachgalten
wird um über diese diese innere
Zwistigkeiten zu kitten denken Sie
einfach nur mal daran dass in Syrien der
syrische Präsident Milli hunderttausende
seiner eigenen Bürger umgebracht hat
allein das schon ist dann ein Zeichen
wie tief die Risse innerhalb der
arabischen Welt sind wenn wir also von
einer arabischen Koalition sprechen die
gegen Israel kämpfen würde dann sprechen
wir sicher nicht von der ägyptischen
Armee eine der größten Armeen der Welt
sondern wir sprechen von diesem
Konglomerat von Milizen die der Iran in
den vergangenen Jahrzehnten aufgebaut
hat übrigens auch mit Geldern die er
erhalten hat im Rahmen des
nuklearabkommens das ja der Westen mit
unterzeichnet hat äh es geht um 100.000
Soldaten im Libanon unter der Hisbollah
die mehr als 150.000 Raketen besitzen
die jeden Punkt in Israel erreichen
können wir sprechen von 10ta000enden
militionären auch der hisbolla und auch
von anderen Organisationen in Syrien wir
sprechen von
hunderttausenden militionären im Irak
und wir sprechen von den hütirebell huti
Rebellen wieder 10tausende also das ist
schon eine beachtliche Kraft nicht dass
es ihr gelingen kann Israel mit
Infanterie zu erobern aber für Israel
ist das dennoch eine existenzielle
Bedrohung denn wir sprechen hier von
einem Beschuss mit hunderttausenden
Raketen aus den verschiedensten
Richtungen das kann selbst die
Raketenabwehr der Israelis nicht
gleichzeitig abwehren und das heißt
selbst wenn Israel in einem Krieg gegen
diese Koalition siegreich sein würde und
wahrscheinlich sein wird wird das Israel
am Tag danach anders aussehen ein Israel
ohne Elektrizitätswerke ohne
mehrwasserinalzungsanlagen mit
10tausenden Toten und Hunderttausenden
wenn nicht Millionen Obdachlosen mm
unser Zuschauer Tobi fragt halten Sie es
für möglich dass man die Hamas komplett
auslöschen
kann es hängt davon ab wie man die Hamas
definiert wenn wir davon sprechen von
den militärischen Fähigkeiten der Hamas
ich glaube dann sind die Israelis imste
durch einen Einmarsch den hamaskämpfern
eine Reibungsfläche zu bieten die
letztlich dazu führen wird dass die
militärischen Kapazitäten der Hamas
erheblich degradiert werden die Israelis
werden Waffenfabriken zerstören
Munitionsdepots Kommandozentralen sie
werden sich Kämpfe liefern mit
hamaskämpfern und denen des
palästinensischen Islamischen Jihad und
militärisch wird die Hamas nach se einem
Krieg nicht mehr so aussehen wie vorher
aber wir dürfen etwas anderes nicht
vergessen die Hamas ist weitaus mehr als
eine Terrororganisation mit bewaffneten
Kämpfern die Hamas ist eine soziale
Bewegung eine gesellschaftliche äh
Organisation sie ist eine politische
Partei die von mehr als einem Drittel
der Palästinenser vor dem Krieg
unterstützt wur nach dem Krieg
wahrscheinlich noch viel größere
Zustimmung erhalten wird
das heißt sie ist eine Idee und eine
Idee lassen sich mit S lässt sich mit
Soldaten nicht besiegen da muss man
schon mit besseren Ideen kommen und das
ist eine Invasion wahrscheinlich nicht
abschreckende Symbole sind ja auch schon
seit kurz nach dieser Terrorattacke
irgendwie präsent die USA haben
verschiedene Sachen ins
in Richtung Israel geschickt und Bettina
fragt uns gerade stimmt es dass
chinesische Kriegsschiffe im Mittelmeer
sind haben sie da Kenntnis
drüber dazu habe ich keine Information
mm dann bleibt abschließend noch mal die
Sache Herr jaron über die ich gerne mit
Ihnen sprechen möchte wir hatten es
gerade schon erwähnt es gibt eine
aktuelle
Umfrage die besagt 49% der Israelis
würden es begrüßen dass die
Bodenoffensive verzögert wird sie haben
ja sich sozusagen auch jetzt in den
letzten Wochen ausgiebig mit der Region
mit den Israelis beschäftigt wohin
glauben sie wird der Krieg und der ganze
Konflikt jetzt in den nächsten Tagen
Wochen
gehen ich glaube nicht dass wir
letztlich von einer bodenoperation in
irgendeinem in irgendeiner Form dass
sich das verhindern werden lässt dafür
haben die Israelis jetzt schon zu viel
in die wagschal geworden geworfen haben
100000 Reservisten rekrutiert und
mobilisiert und das tun sie nicht um
einfach nur am Gazastreifen an der
Grenze zu stehen und zuzugucken wie die
Luftwaffe das bombardiert die Frage ist
nur welche Form wird eine solche
Invasion nehmen wird Israel wirklich
große Teile des Gazastreifens äh
besetzen in Besitz nehmen oder werden
wir mehr sehen von diesen incursions von
diesen nächtlichen vor allem nächtlichen
Einfällen weil die Israelis ja einen
großen Vorteil haben im Nachtkampf
gegenüber der chamas dass sie sozusagen
Spezial trainierte Einheiten in den
gaserstreifen schicken und immer wieder
äh bekannte Orte der Hamas anzugreifen
oder vielleicht zu versuchen Geisen zu
befreien und die anderen Soldaten stehen
sozusagen nur äh als Rückhalt dort um
eventuell Hilfe zu leisten falls die bei
diesen Einsätzen
ein kompliziertes Szenario entsteht all
das ist noch unbekannt aber die
israelische Regierung spricht davon dass
es hier sich nicht um eine Operation
handeln wird die eine Woche oder zwei
oder drei Wochen dauern wird sondern es
wird um eine monatelange Operation gehen
es geht darum wirklich eine
existenzielle Bedrohung Israels von der
Grenze zu entfernen und wir dürfen nicht
vergessen die existiert nicht nur im
Gazastreifen die existiert auch an der
Grenze zum Libanon auch dort stehen
israelische Soldaten bereit dort wurden
bereits 1000 israelische Zivilisten aus
ihren Häusern evakuiert weil man Angst
hat dass in jeder Sekunde diebolla sich
nicht mehr damit begnügen wird nur
Raketen auf Häuser abzuschießen sondern
dass sie ein ähnlichen Angriff Wagen
kann mit ihrer raduanforce einer anderen
Division an ihren elitekämpfern um
ebenfalls israelische Zivilisten in den
Libanon zu verschleppen das ist ein
Zustand den Israel nicht dulden kann und
nicht dulden wird und so ist die Frage
wie lange wird der Krieg auf den
gaserstreifen begrenzt bleiben glaube
ich eine sehr akute unsere Zuschauer
blicken auch auf die letzten drei Wochen
zurück was da passiert ist bei dieser
Terrorattacke quantolino fragt wie
konnte es sein dass die bestbewachte
Grenze durch so viele hamasterroristen
überwunden werden konnte sie ist ja
eigentlich bestens abgesichert er
schreibt jede Schlange wird da
wahrgenommen ja also ich glaube die
endgültige Antwort werden wir erst nach
dem Krieg erfahren wenn eine israelische
Untersuchungskommission das versucht
festzustellen aber was wir jetzt schon
wissen sind ein paar Anhaltspunkte die
wir haben der erste Punkt ist dass die
chamastas einfach sehr sehr schlau
geplant hat und zwar seit einer geraumen
Zeit seit mehr als 2wei Jahren arbeitet
die Hamas an diesen Angriffsplänen sie
hat dabei wahrscheinlich auch
logistische und geheimdienstliche
Gehilfe von außen erhalten und sie hat
die Israelis schlichtweg an der Nase
herumgeführt die Israelis haben viel von
diesen Vorbereitungen gesehen haben sie
aber falsch interpretiert ja nur wenige
Tage vor der Invasion des Gazastreifens
haben hamaskämpfer eine solche
Überquerung der der der Grenzanlagen und
eine Eroberung von einer israelischen
Ortschaft bei helligem Tag vor den
offenen Augen der Israelis geprobt aber
die Israelis haben gesagt
die wollen das nicht das ist nur eine
Probe die wollen Israel nicht angreifen
die Israelis waren davon überzeugt die
Hamas wird immer pragmatischer ihr
Interesse ist den Gazastreifen zu
kontrollieren zu regieren und nicht
einen Krieg gegen Israel zu führen diese
irglauben hat die Hamas aktiv durch sehr
schlaue Täuschungsmanöver befördert und
jetzt stehen die Israel V Israelis vor
einer anderen Realität nämlich der
Realität die besagt die Hamas will das
was in ihrer Karter steht ganz offen
genauso wie Hitler in sein Kampf von der
Auslöschung des jüdischen Volkes spricht
so spricht auch die Hamas davon dass sie
Juden auslöschen will und dass sie
Israel vernichten will und es ist an der
Zeit dass man das geschriebene Wort der
chamas dass sie nach langem denken so
formuliert und verabschiedet hat auch
ernst nimmt das ist die Meinung in
Israel sie ist eine Organisation die
nicht pragmatischer werden will sondern
den Staat Israel auslöschen und das ist
der Grund warum Israel sagt Frieden wird
es in nen Osten nur geben wenn die Hamas
nicht mehr ein wichtiger Player in
dieser Region ist ja mit dem oder
innerhalb dieser Terrorattacke wurden
auch mehrere hundert Menschen als
Geiseln genommen von der Hamas befinden
sich auch mit unter immer noch in Haft
der Hamas in Geiselhaft und wir hatten
vorhin schon kurz einen Ausschnitt
gezeigt aus der UN volollversammlung die
da gerade läuft dass sich der Erzfeind
Israels da auf die Bühne stellt und ein
Angebot macht mit mehreren tausend
palästinensischen Häftlingen im Gegenzug
würden einzelne Geiseln freigelassen
glauben Sie dass die israelische
Regierung sich auf solch einen Deal
einlassen würde
nein völlig absturd und abstrus und
ich würde sagen es grenzt ans perfide es
ist so ähnlich wie wenn Herr Putin
der der
Präsident Russlands die Israelis dazu
anhält dass man doch bei jedem Krieg
Zivilisten schonen muss
wenn das aus den Worten aus den aus dem
Mund von Putin kommt sie können schon
verstehen mit wie viel Sarkasmus man so
etwas wahrnehmen muss ein ähnlicher
Sarkasmus
gebührt eigentlich den Aussagen des
Irans der Iran der überhaupt zu diese
diese geiselnamen überhaupt er
ermöglicht hat will davon jetzt auch
noch diplomatisch profitieren und ich
glaube dass es den Geiseln im Iran kein
Deut besser gehen würde als im
Augenblick im Gazastreifen
Einschätzungen vom Journalisten und
naostexerten Gil Ron waren das her Ron
vielen Dank für das Gespräch und ja ein
schönes Wochenende für
Sie
genau das war unser ZDF heute live für
heute wir sagen wieder danke für alle
eure in Kommentare und Meinungen zu
diesem Thema das uns sicherlich auch in
der kommenden Woche weiter beschäftigen
wird ähm wenn es was neues gibt dann
werdet ihr ja auf alle Fälle auf dem
Laufenden gehalten bis dann wünschen wir
euch eine gute Zeit und sagen tschüss
und bis
[Musik]
bald